bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 78 weekend vous le savez votre
émission hebdomadaire consacrée à
l'actualité loisirs sport et culture de
la semaine et des jours prochains au
cours de cette émission nous parlerons
idées de sortie pour les prochaines
semaines du mois de décembre notamment
avec la directrice d'iveline Sylvie
launa nous évoquerons également dans
notre page spéciale dédié au spectacle
et au théâtre avec notre journaliste
yolen Torz c'est coup de cœur pour les
prochains jours et les scènes à ne pas
rater mais tout d'abord place au
loisirs et si vous n'avez pas d'idée de
sortie pour le mois de décembre voici le
petit guide pratique de Sylvie laouna
directrice d'iveline tourisme bonjour
Sylvie merci de passer sur le plateau du
78 weekend alors tout d'abord vous allez
nous emmener du côté du château de
Versailles alors on va aller voir des
expositions puisqu'il commence à faire
un petit peu froid d'ici peu donc c'est
un moyen d'être à l'intérieur de ne pas
avoir froid donc il y a une exposition
au domaine national de Versailles qui
s'appelle 18e aux sources du design et
là on va découvrir comment des créateurs
de mobilier comme André Charles boule ou
George Jacob ont un peu révolutionné les
techniques on va apprendre en voyant
tous ces meubles il y en a une centaine
qui vont du canapé au fauteuil en
passant par la chaise au secrétaire au
bureau et on va découvrir quel étaiit
les goûts de l'époque l'évolution des
goûts de l'époque et et le goût de luxe
que du luxe qu'on avait à cette époque
du 18e oui d'ailleurs une exposition
qu'on vous a fait découvrir sur TVfil 78
et puis sinon pour les passionnés
d'antiquité tout autre sujet tout autre
domaine vous pourrez découvrir ou
redécouvrir vos connaissances de la
graisse alors c'est au Domaine national
hein de Saint-Germain en laai où cette
belle exposition qui a commencé déjà où
il y a il y a quelques mois qui
s'appelle de la Grèce des origines euh
du rêve à l'archéologie et qui propose
effectivement de redécouvrir euh ce
peuple grec qui était très très en
avance euh par rapport à l'époque et
donc on a tout un tas de d'animations
d'ateliers qui sont proposés euh par
exemple il existe existe des ateliers
pour savoir comment faire des masques ou
des des bijoux des héros de la grisse
puis on peut aussi avoir une initiation
aux techniques de granulation des
archéologues ou alors découvrir
l'écriture des des myéniens qui est une
écriture assez mystérieuse donc plein de
choses à faire on peut
aussi savoir comment sont réalisés les
les bijoux donc plein de choses pour les
enfants pour les familles au Musée
national d'archéologie à pour découvrir
toute l'inventivité évidemment de cette
population de l'Antiquité on repart sur
un autre château du côté de maison
Lafite et là cette fois-ci place au
fantômes c'est encore autre chose ça
s'appelle lanterne magique et
fantasmagorie et c'est au château de
maison Lafite cette fois-ci donc une
exposition où on va découvrir les
spectres les revenants les fantômes tels
qu'ils ont été euh traité dans le le
théâtre et le cinéma à l'époque du 19e
alors je parle pas du cinéma du 19e il y
en avait pas hein des films qui ont
trait au 19e siècle et euh donc il y a
aussi de la même façon des des ateliers
euh et et des types de de visites qui
sont proposés euh à maison la fite pour
les familles et les enfants et vous le
savez hein cette année c'est évidemment
le centenaire de la Grande Guerre la
Première Guerre mondiale 14 18 et donc
du coup si vous avez des souvenirs vous
pourrez les faire partager notamment
voilà alors le Conseil général a lancé
le wiki de la grande guerre alors
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est le système de
Wikipédia bien sûr la Grande
Encyclopédie que tout le monde connaît
où on peut rentrer des informations sur
des connaissances que l'on a sur des
lieux sur des personnages ou sur des
sites des connaissances sur ce qu'ils
étaient ce qu'ils ont vécu au moment de
la grande guerre donc on peut témoigner
sur ce sur ce wiki de la Grande Guerre
donc c'est tout à fait ouvert que tout
le monde puisse participer à tout ça oui
pour approfondir évidemment les
connaissances des conditions de vie des
des poilus au front et autre sujet là on
va parler un petit peu plus farnienté un
peu de de brunch notamment c'est ça dans
les prochaines semaines qu'on peut faire
le le weekend alors on a oublié des
petites choses dans les expos quand même
sont
je suis allé trop vite oui c'est ça vous
voulez me me couper dans mon élan TR
trop de gourmandise c'est ça vous aviez
hâte de manger et bien pas encore il y a
encore quelques expositions et il y a
aussi un jeu concours qui est qui est
gueule d'ange qui est fait par le
Conseil Général aussi c'est un poilu on
doit suivre sa trace c'est une espèce de
petit jeu mais qui est didactique on
apprend plein de choses sur la Grande
Guerre et puis si on est tiré au sort si
on a répondu à toutes les questions
enfin si on est arrivé au bout du
parcours on est tiré au sort on a un
cadeau à la fin donc ça c'est
intéressant et deux autres expos qui
sont aussi sur le thème de la Grande
Guerre euh c'est à Rambouillet cette
fois-ci et c'est les jeux de lois de la
Grande Guerre et
c'est à
l'hôtel que je au palais du roi de de
Rome à Rambouillet pardon et ensuite il
y a une autre exposition aussi qui est
au musée promenade qui s'appelle
publicité et propagande allons enfants
et c'est à louvcienne voilà cette
fois-ci maintenant on va passer donc au
brunch la partie gourmande de votre
chronique alors tout d'abord on va
partir du côté de Saint-Germain en lait
oui alors de nouveau à Saint-Germain en
lait mais pas du tout pour la même chose
ce sont les brunches de caso dehor et la
Forestière alors caso dehors et la
Forestière c'est en pleine forêt de
Saint-Germain comme le nom l'indique qui
propose le dimanche des animations pour
la famille autour du brunch alors
évidemment c'est assez gastronomique
parce que caso dehor c'est quand même un
un Relais et Château il y a des roulades
de bœuf au basilic il y a des huîtres
il y a tout un chose un tas de choses un
peu haut de gamme autour de du basique
du brunch les œufs brouillés les
vieniseries et puis pour les enfants il
y a un clown qui est venu qui va vous
faire des des des comment des animations
autour du ballon hein qui va faire des
sculptures de ballon et il s'appelle
colelo et c'est le clown le plus rigolo
évidemment évidemment ça va de soi autre
brunch autre idée de gourmandise du côté
de Cerny la ville alors cette fois-ci
effectivement c'est c'est un brunch qui
va se dérouler au salon Léopold à cernet
la ville alors c'est un peu plus
classique parce que il y a des
animations comme à CERN la ville au
salon léopol il y a toujours des
animations autour de la danse il va y
avoir des fonds musicaux mais également
un té dansant après le le brunch on fait
séterniser un peu le brunch et on danse
et il y a des buffets à volonté sur tout
un tas de choses il y a des buffets de
crudité il y a des buffets de de gâteau
de toutes sortes voilà et c'est en
pleine Val de Chevreuse et avec des
produits fait maison qui viennent des
fermes avoisinantes dernier brunch pour
les les plus gourmands peut-être du côté
de marlee Leroi voilà alors c'est
vraiment le brunch à l'anglaise puisque
c'est au cottage que ça se passe le le
cottage il est dans la grande rue la
Grand Rue même à à Marly et donc ce
cottage vous propose bah toujours pareil
les SCON les les
Bronis et les muffins autour des thé et
café délices et puis puis bah vous avez
les grandes assiettes l'assiette
nordique c'est des assiettes par thème
qui peuvent être associé au brunch
classique merci beaucoup Sylvie d'être
passé sur le 78 weekend et puis
évidemment des idées que vous pourrez
retrouver en partie sur le site sortir
eveline.fr une autre info pour être
complet sur vos idées de sortie loisir
vous pourrez découvrir tout ce weekend
29 et 30 novembre le marché de Noël
d'amnesy internationale 40 artisans
créateurs vous accueilleront avec leurs
jeux et jouets leurs décorations ou
accessoires entre 10h et 19h à l'école
des Condamines de Versailles il y aura
notamment au programme un spectacle
gratuit pour enfants ce dimanche 30
novembre à 15h allez on enchaîne avec
notre page spéciale
théâtre et je le disais dans les titres
de cette émission cette semaine c'est
donc les coups de cœur de notre
journaliste yolen Torz bonjour yolen
merci d'être là alors quelle pièce il va
falloir absolument aller voir dans ces
prochains jours alors la première donc
elle s'appelle ce qui boîent c'est une
création contemporaine de la compagnie
du Théâtre de cher et ce weekend ce sont
les toutes premières représentations qui
qui vous sont proposées avant que la
troupe la troupe nentame sa tournée en
Île-de-France alors les huit acteurs de
de la pièce se produisent dans un
théâtre atypique il est en effet situé
au beau milieu de l'hôpital
psychiatrique de la verrière au sein de
l'Institut Marcel Rivière pour autant
pas d'appréhension il s'agit d'un thére
comme un autre la troupe du Théâtre de
cher aura 10 ans l'année prochaine et
c'est la 3è année qu'ils sont implantés
à La Verrière nous les avons rencontré
afin d'en savoir un petit peu plus sur
cette pièce les images sont signées
William
l ce qui boitent c'est l'histoire d'un
homme qu'on retrouve totalement
amenésique dans un accident de la route
et on comprend pas d'où il vient il y a
pas de voiture à son nom il a pas de
bagage pas de papier il y a rien sur lui
qui permet de l'identifier et la pièce
va raconter la reconstruction de cet
homme suite à cet
accident il va croiser le destin
d'autres personnages qui ont aussi des
des parcours de vie cabossé et c'est une
pièce qui à travers ces histoires là qui
se tissent les unes avec les autres pour
reconstituer l'histoire de Claude le
personnage
principal traite de la résilience de la
reconstruction comment est-ce qu'à
travers la mise en récit de nos vies se
construit ou se reconstruit une identité
et un rapport au
monde qu' y a vraiment cette cette
histoire de de double alors c'était
justement à travers le reflet le la
Stelle de verre amène comme un miroir
cette histoire de double et puis il y a
aussi cette question de de l'opacité de
la vie de l'histoire du personnage
central et que ces Stell de verre selon
la manière dont
vont être éclairé elles vont être soit
des miroirs soit des transparentes soit
au contraire on va peiner avoir à
travers parce que les les miroir va être
très présent donc il a un petit peu
aussi tous ces jeux de de mystère et de
dévoilement tu te souviens tu te
souviens
pas tu te
souviens tu te souviens
pas tu te souviens
pas à
bientôt
ok donc samedi à 19h et dimanche à 15h
deux occasion donc de découvrir cette
pièce ce weekend vous pouvez réserver
mais aussi vous décider à la dernière
minute et acheter vos places sur place
et pour ceux qui ne sont pas disponibles
ce weekend une séance de rattrapage est
possible lors de leur prochaine étape ce
sera le 12 décembre 20h30 au Théâtre de
Fontenet lefleurri une autre idée de
sortie de théâtre encore Yolène avant de
partir alors c'est au prise mail en
cours que ça se passe cette fois-ci la
pièce de théâtre s'appelle c'est Noël
tant pis on y retrouve cinq membres
d'une famille traditionnelle le soir de
Noël il se déchire se juge se condamne
parfois bref un humour grinçant domine
le spectacle il sera joué ce vendredi 28
et ce samedi 29 novembre à 21h voici la
bandeannonce vas-y Bernard c'est toi qui
commence ça c'est moi qui commence mais
discute pas commence bon moi je joue le
rôle du père c'est le soir de Noël et on
peut tout de suite dire que c'est pas
simple simple c'est le soir de Noël ou
c'est ce que j'ai dit je joue le rôle de
la mère bon ben allez c'est à vous les
enfants moi je joue le rôle du fils et
toi tu dis rien qu'est-ce que tu veux
que je dise il n'y a qu'un seul fils
dans cette
pièce je joue le rôle du deuxième fils
voilà tu aurais pu dire cadet tu as dit
deè c'est toute ta vie ça on joue de
frère et c'est le soir de Noël c'est le
soir de Noël et c'est une grande fête de
famille je ne suis pas sûre qu'on puisse
dire ça ça se passe plus le soir de Noël
que c'est une grande fête de famille et
moi personne ne me présente personne n'a
présenté personne pourquoi tu ferais
exception tu es une actrice
exceptionnelle elle c'est jeune vibe la
jolie pièce rapportée et ça se passe le
soir de Noël je pense que tout le monde
a bien compris quand ça se passait ça se
passe d'abord autour du sapin puis ça se
poursuit à l'hôpital le 31 décembre et
ça finit très mal mais non bah si pour
moi si non de toute façon moi j'ai
jamais rien compris à cette pièce
d'abord
on retrouve la grand-mère sous la table
ensuite tout le monde se retrouve à
l'hôpital et c'est là que ça commence à
dégénérer mais à dégénérer vraiment la
famille explose en plein vol c'est quand
même une comédie pas pour tout le monde
mais si il est quand même question des
petites catastrophes humaines au sein du
plus grand rid sociétal judéochrétien
oui mais enfin c'est quand même une
comédie ça n'est pas que drôle j'espère
qu'on va quand même un peu s'amuser on
fera ce qu'on
pourra et voilà les idées de sortie
théâtre de yolen Torz merci beaucoup
yolen à très bientôt on enchaîne avec la
culture la Maison de la poésie à
guillancour accueille en ce moment même
l'artiste et metteur en scène Charles
Gonzalez pour un travail autour
d'Antonin Arto 15 personnes d'ailleurs
participent à des ateliers autour des
textes de ce poète du surréalisme
Catherine
zulat
messieurs les lois
la
coutume vous concède le droit de mesurer
l'esprit pendant 11 séances ici à la
Maison de la poésie à Guill encour ils
vont faire défaire construire les
paroles d'Anton
un auteur poète comédien inclassable à
la frontière du réel et de la folie
combien êtes-vous par exemple pour qui
le rêve du dém précoce les images dont
il est la proie sont autre chose qu'une
salade de mot en tant qu'acteur pour
nous
correspond est un père spirituel pour
pour nous tous pour son de la de la
cruauté pour également parce que j'ai
aussi écrit un livre qui s'appelle récit
d' no obscure qui explique la sortie de
de l'hôpital psychiatrique voilà pour
une espèce de libération et pascart
c'est certainement
théâtralement un
homme dont les idées sont utopiques mais
qui 15 personnes iné atelier qui va donc
durer pendant 11 séances à raison de 4h
par session ils ne sont pas comédiens ni
artistes juste passionnés de poésie je
sais comment elle me regarde la poésie
me plaît oui oui ça me parle c'est c'est
la construction c'est ce sont les
lettres la construction des mots voilà
donc les fras c'est la matière grise
c'est un moyen de
s'exprimer qui est qui a gardé cette
fraîcheur de liberté qui peut-être hélas
n'existe pas dans d'autres domaines
artistiques moi-même je suis maintenant
à la retraite artiste peintre j'ai une
association depuis 20 ans où j'enseigne
effectivement or je regarde un peu ce
qui se passe dans le marché de l'art et
je vois que la liberté est devenue très
relative donc la poésie pour moi c'est
le domaine de la liberté je pour la
première question à qui s'adresse ton
à un personnage mental quelles sont tes
exigences d'actante moi je pensensez
m'adresser à eux non d'accord très bien
les gens ne sont pas des acteurs mais
des actants c'està-dire des gens venant
de de lieux tout à fait différents et
c'est une approche naïve donc ça risque
d'avoir de vraiment de très bonnes
surprises la façon de dire to est
surprenante par des gens qui qui ne font
pas l'acteur quoi je vous assure vous
allez voir ça ça don des choses
surprenantes le résultat de ces ateliers
sera à découvrir le 11 avril prochain à
la Maison de la
poésie éduité des
peuples neuf le le château accueille
jusqu'au 30 novembre le 9e Salon des
Photographes et d'ailleurs 20
professionnels y sont conviés parmi eux
deux cquantinois à découvrir avec
Catherine
zulato jérôme chérrier est un habitué du
salon cette année parmi ses photos des
clichés pris lors de son dernier voyage
au Népal un pays qui souligne le
photographe marque beaucoup un vrai
dépaysement et des émotions avant en
fait je je regarde effectivement pas mal
de de livres photos de ce qui peut se se
se faire en photo j'adapte aussi mon
matériel je sais un peu près ce que je
vais prendre et puis après c'est un
petit peu de l'improvisation on se
promène dans les rues on voit ce qui se
passe on essaie de faire des des photos
de rue des portraits c'est c'est pas mal
d'improvisation tout en ayant une un
petit fil rouge qui est pas mal d'humain
et de paysage et Jérôme chérrier prépare
déjà sa prochaine expédition ce sera le
Vietnam
julien duem lui aime l'univers musical
il capte les images de concert un
travail très technique il y a toujours
de de l'ineattendu dans les concerts et
c'est vrai qu'on est là pour saisir des
instants c'est pas des c'est pas de la
photo dirigée particulièrement donc
l'objectif c'est de saisir un petit peu
des instants qui passent très très vite
le père de l'un était photographe le
père de l'autre peintre autodidacte les
deux artistes ont baignés dans un
univers propice alors quand on leur
demande de décrire une bonne photo le
premier mot qui leur vient c'est émotion
pour le photographe le but c'est bien
sûr de
de de générer des émotions aux gens qui
qui la regarde moi ce que j'aime c'est
quand les gens viennent et puis
s'arrêtent devant marque un temps
d'arrêt en fait c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'arrête pour la regarder et pas juste
passer à partir du moment où les gens
s'arrêtent et commencent à vous parler
de vos photos d'une de vos photos c'est
que pour moi je pense que le contrat est
est réussi quoi quand on arrive à capter
la lumière de la bonne manière quoi à
capter la bonne expression et ben on
peut on peut être endre ces photos quoi
l'exposition se termine le 30 novembre
20 photographes sont conviés pas de
thématique commune la place est laissée
à l'éclectisme c'est d'ailleurs la
marque de fabrique du
salon le modélisme morpa club organisé
ce weekend la 8e édition de sa course
d'endurance de slot racing une
discipline qui permet aux passionnés de
compétition automobilees de devenir un
peu l'ér des circuits pour seulement
quelques dizaines d'euros reportage
réalisé avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud des vitesses de pote allant
jusqu'à 400 km/h un tour bouclé en 7
secondes bienvenue dans le monde du slot
pour cette 8e édition des 6h de morpa
ne9u équipes de trois pilotes
s'affrontent sur un circuit de 6 voix à
l'échelle 1 32e et ici nous sommes loin
du simple jeu offert à Noël aux enfants
en endurance la prime est à la
régularité du chronomètre la
concentration devient alors la base la
précision vitale ça paraît extrêmement
facile et d'ailleurs c'est pas très
compliqué pour avoir un un niveau moyen
par contre c'est c'est un jeu d'adresse
ça va être comme du tir à l'arc ou du
tir à la carabine il va falloir faire
toujours le même geste être le plus
précis possible et c'est un véritable
jeu d'adresse et pour aller chercher les
derniers cè et les derniers 10è c'est
des heures et des heures et des heures
d'entraînement la dextérité des pilotes
est d'autant plus sollicité sur cette
course que chaque dernier quart d'heure
de session se conclut en nocturne dans
le slot le pilotage est tout aussi
important que la performance intrinsèque
de la voiture car détrompez-vous même à
l'échelle un 32e le moindre détail de
préparation compte les autos en général
c'est les équipes qui les fournissent
elle se prépar selon un règlement
technique donc les les voitures on
essaie de les adapter le mieux possible
à la piste à sa forme s'il y a très
longue ligne droite par exemple on va
mettre des transmissions très longues
s'il y a très peu de ligne droite on va
mettre des transmissions très courtes et
cetera les pneus aussi sont importants
malgré la compétition la convivialité
règne dans une discipline où l'on peut
devenir le roi des circuits pour
quelques dizaines d'euros une poignée
d'assez bonne qualité il faut compter
une cinquantaine d'euros après on a des
poignées plus cherr parce que là on fait
appel à l'électronique au niveau d'un
véhicule un 32e avec une voiture à 50 €
on peut déjà bien s'amuser sur leur
nouvelle piste en bois les pilotes de
morpa s'impose à domicile au terme des 6
heures de course après
2790 tours par cours r on enchaîne avec
votre agenda sportif du weekend et deux
matchs à ne pas rater tout d'abord du
rugby pour le compte de la 9e journée de
fédéral 2 plaisir pourra confirmer son
renouveau avec la réception du 7e
d'umont coup d'envoi à 15h ce dimanche
au stade Robert Baran il y aura aussi du
basket National 3 au programme 10e
journée le derby entre l'entente le chîn
et versaill et le 2èe poissi coup
d'envoie à 20h ce samedi au gymnase
montburon on en enchaîne avec le
cinéma et comme toutes les semaines
notre petit coup d'œil sur les salles
obscures cette semaine c'est gaell Pinot
du grenier à celle à trrappe qui vous
délivre un coup de cœur un petit peu
particulier bonjour cette semaine je
voudrais vous parler d'un débat qui aura
lieu le mardi 9 décembre à 20h45 donc la
semaine prochaine au cinéma le grrenier
à sattrape il s'agit d'un un débat d'une
rencontre avec Marie Monique Robin pour
le film sacré croissance qui est passé
sur har il y a quelques semaines Marie
Monique Robin qui avait déjà fait le
monde le mon s Notre poison quotidien
Les Moissons du futur donc elle est elle
est assez connue dans le monde du
documentaire vous avez certainement vu
un de ces documentaires là et donc elle
viendra au grenier à selle pour
présenter son prochain film qui
s'appelle sacré
croissance
c'est un documentaire qui interroge sur
comment dire le dogme de de la
croissance et qui montre des solutions
qui montre du nord au sud des solutions
alternatives au problèm de au modèle de
la croissance donc ça peut être dans des
domaines de l'alimentaire dans des
domaines de l'énergie de l'échange de
biens et de servic et cetera celui qui
pense qu'une croissance exponentielle
infini est possible dans un monde fini
et soit un fou soit un économiste
donc on parlera tout ça mardi 9 décembre
à 20h45 vous retrouvez toutes ces infos
sur notre site Internet
www.cinemagrenierac.com vous pouvez
réserver au 30 69 84 62 et donc je vous
dis à la semaine
prochaine c'est la fin de cette édition
merci encore une fois de l'avoir suivi
je vous souhaite un excellent weekend
sur
TV